UN has voted overwhelmingly in support
of lifting the US economic and finance
embargo on Cuba it is the 27th time that
the Assembly has issued the call to end
the Caribbean crisis era restrictions
America's m'boy though - the UN has
lashed out at those who voted against
the u.s. position once again we were
reminded why so many people believe that
faith in the United Nations is often
misplaced the brutal whims of the Castro
dictatorship denial of freedom and the
denial of the most basic human rights
for the Cuban people the people of Cuba
are our neighbors and our friends and
they are fellow children of God they use
this all the time that's the word
bandied around but these are
democratically elected people as you've
known it really flies in the face of a
country that just announced having voter
suppression of methods in the United
States these are popular governments
with with participation voter
participation percentages that far
outstrip the United States there's you
only have about a little over 50% now
after Barack Obama of the Pope of the
electorate participating or the the
citizens in the United States
participating in elections in Cuba it's
like 80 percent these acts are
completely against the spirit and the
foundation of the United Nations Charter
they are via flagrant violations of the
sovereignty of Nations none of these
countries have posed any threat
whatsoever to the United States or to
any other countries
you